we begin this morning with the
politically charged opening of the
winter olympics in beijing the chinese
capital is the first city to host both
the summer and winter games during the
opening ceremonies the cauldron was lit
by a chinese skier who was part of
china's weaker muslim minority
china's government has been condemned
for its treatment of uyghurs an
estimated 1 million are being held in
mass internment camps while many western
leaders are boycotting the games russian
president vladimir putin met privately
with china's xi xi ping the two emerged
from the meeting by sending a message to
the west their joint statements saying
that china and russia's alliance has no
limits
jamie yukas is covering the winter games
in beijing jamie good morning
good morning nearly every olympic sport
saw action today and the first medals
now awarded norway's therese johag won
the women's ski-a-thon the games
officially were opened and dedicated
here at the national stadium also known
as the bird's nest in a captivating and
controversial ceremony
pageantry on display but far from a full
house due to covet restrictions
the 24th winter olympic games are now
open athletes from 90 different
countries and territories marched
through china's national stadium on a
cold and blustery night leading the way
for team usa's 224 competitors curler
john shuster
in his fifth olympic appearance he was
chosen along with speed skater brittany
beau to be america's flag bearer john
have to ask what was last night like as
an athlete being
i guess
chosen to
carry your flag of your country to lead
your delegation into an opening
ceremonies is
kind of the ultimate and capturing that
ultimate moment was curler becca
hamilton her brother matt one of john's
teammates
i don't know if she realized it when she
took it kind of felt very fitting that
john was up there and the four of his
teammates behind linked arm and arm just
had his back bob's letter alana
myers-taylor was supposed to handle the
honors but was forced into isolation by
a positive covet test we spoke to her
before the ceremony we've been on the
road since november 10th and never came
back to the u.s for fear of catching
kovid so to get it here it was pretty
devastating
the pandemic and politics have become a
backdrop for these games with chinese
president xi jinping looking on an
athlete from china's marginalized uyghur
community lit the cauldron
while many saw it as a response to
criticism of china's human rights record
an olympic spokesperson says the skier
was not chosen based on her ethnic
background this is an athlete who is
competing here she's competing as i say
i think this morning she has
every right wherever she comes from
whatever her background to compete and
she has every right whatever her
background wherever she comes from to
take part in the opening ceremony this
after she's meeting with russia's
vladimir putin in which the two leaders
appeared to cement their country's
relations and stand in opposition to the
u.s and western interests
they're not allies they're even closer
stephen lee myers is beijing bureau
chief for the new york times i think
that they've telegraphed
both leaders a desire to assert for
their own countries a place on the world
stage
that challenges the dominance of the
united states
and the west
the women's hockey team is about to face
off against the russians and usa mixed
doubles curling beat china and is now in
position to make it to the medal round
next week the figure skating team event
resumes tomorrow with the usa team
leading after the first round data red
white and blue jamie thank you